Nike suing Vape do you care about this
it is actually interesting because babe
did rip off the Air Force One they
ripped off a bunch of Nike [__] too if
you look at like there's multiple
Silhouettes that Vape has almost the
exact same and I didn't even realize
this Vape has a watch called the vapeex
which looks exactly like a Rolex like
their whole model seems to be like
streetwear yeah it does that but then
this is this isn't this the same like
isn't that just no this is justifiable
Nike suing is justifiable completely but
what I'm saying is what street wear does
is rip off other things I guess to me
this is crazy but I feel like you didn't
even listen well that's what it felt
like he'll be doing it
and then paying attention can you just
acknowledge what I said yes this is what
streetwear is what is it it is copying
other people's [__] that's like high
designer and then pawning it off as your
own okay be therapized look at that that
was good yeah
the small thing I just figured out what
you were saying a little early
that's good you felt I'm gonna try to
finish it though I'm gonna keep that
okay and this might be stupid and small
but calling it Vape X so even the
writing looks exactly like Rolex to me
it was like now it's too much if it's
just the dial is the same and the the
bezel is the same all right I see that
but when you're making the font the same
and spelling it out the same with the ex
at the end it's like this seems on this
I feel like they do that so that you
can't say to them Yo you're just copying
Rolex they make it so obviously
so it's like yes exactly like oh you're
just wearing some knockoff Air Force
Ones it's like yeah dummy that's the
idea knocked off Air Force Ones or they
knocked off Rolex or whatever it is I
have no problem with Nike going yo
you're piggybacking on our [__] the [__]
you doing like the crazy thing about
Nike that we well I thought that they
were going to do this one big first job
because there was Rumblings of them like
doing some cease and decisions yeah but
now they just let this brand become
gigantic and now you can hit him with
the crazy joints
early when it's still a young company or
let them grow big and then hit them with
some crazy [__] apparently they had a
meeting in 2009 so like I think the baby
stuff that top one that ripped the Air
Force One came out like 20 years ago and
so and like in Japan and it was like
really popular in Japan and like parts
of Europe but then it kind of came over
and then in 2009 Nike had a meeting with
babe like behind closed doors like
discuss infringement and then never
executed on the lawsuit yeah there was
talks of it I remember that I wonder if
they tried to buy them and then babe
said no and then Nike was like all right
then your whole [__] is over maybe
there's also something to be said it's
interesting people have brought this up
that actually Nike's also benefited from
babe doing this because it gives value
to the Air Force Ones a lot of the
really cool colorways that came out for
like the Air Force One the dunks like we
started with the babes so babe was like
ripping it and then doing like hot pink
Air Force ones that they that they
thought oh this is like a basketball
shoe no one wants these or like the
dunks oh this is like a sports shoe no
one wants pink and then they came out
with like crazy designs and colorways
and then Nike started doing the same
thing ah so people are like oh well it
actually benefits of both from like a
design perspective I don't know how much
Nike would say that it probably
benefited babe a million times more but
people bring that up I just thought it
was an interesting point this is going
to be crazy because if they lose
in so many companies are getting sued
Steve Madden Aldo all these Brands
Zara h m like that is gonna be nuts
according to the lawsuit I thought there
was something to do with the patent but
then they brought it up according to the
lawsuit the reason they're executing it
now is that it wasn't making that big of
a dent in the American market for Nike
for the longest time and the second is
started and then apparently they also
started doing collabs so like night so
like babe was doing a Marvel collab and
doing like the exclusive Marvels
and now Nike is like you're gonna take
our [__] and take brand opportunities
wow so it's kind of a good lesson if you
are going to bite [__] like stay in your
lane I guess yeah is there any kind of
middle ground in terms of like I'm sorry
to interrupt but that's wow greedy bro
you ripping them off completely yeah and
then you're gonna go to Marvel and be
like yo do a collab with the rip-off of
the Nike but it's also been 20 years I
know babe looks at the brand they're
like we're more than the Vapes though we
are all of this stuff we're everything
that negos created yeah we're like we're
the hoodies we're the you know the bear
what what'd you say his name the
designer what's his name bro nego
what
and I what n-i-g-o
I don't know man
yeah did he rip off another word no I
don't think so he's just a Japanese guy
he didn't slightly change another word
like because this is somebody who likes
to adopt hip-hop culture and make it a
little bit different do you think it's
possible that he adopted another word
and made his name
no I don't think he had any relation to
like black American culture at all move
you sure I mean I think obviously
through Nike but I don't think it was
directly uh you know like in a racial
way
this is the original brand logo holy my
God this guy's a [__] racist we got a
real live [__] racist this guy's an
absolutely racist wait what son Bape
what babe with a B on the front well it
actually stands for bathing hate what do
you call yeah that's why that's a nice
cover what do you call a black nerd
um Poindexter no you call him a blur a
blurred what is he trying to say right
now holy [__] unbelievable Nike Sue that
[__] for everything he's got yup
yup yup this guy's a problem this guy's
a [__] racist problem bro
think about that Al nah because I like
the brands yeah
I thought too but uh
with Gucci remember when Gucci had like
all the racist pictures
we two months away from looking the
other way
but yeah it's very interesting now
they're doing Lululemon on top of that
[Laughter]
you got a nice little travel Nike sweats
I only have one pair of Lulu and it's a
travel sweats Nike sweats too I did not
know and this is not a knock I didn't
know Lululemon made clothes for men
before until you had those pens one pair
you could barely see the logo it's not
bad there's nothing wrong they make nice
no I just didn't know I thought it was
just though I've already closed I need
to have a red Band-Aid at the top when
you first said that I was like is he
wearing red band
red band that's funny but yeah no I
started off as like a woman's brand yeah
like everyone like women's pants yeah do
you have a pair of leggings though right
obviously yeah right leggings no you
weared leggings every time you work out
yes or no underneath yeah that's
something my junk won't fall out oh come
on bro oh
so anyway that's this lawsuit it's very
interesting what do you think
I'm I'm
[Applause]
I mean we've been sending a seasoned
desist from Nike
I mean it's crazy that oh it took maybe
20 years to get that [__] and we got
that [__] with one [__] design
but they got it they heard the footsteps
bro oh they knew yeah they knew but I
listened you just can't fall Nike right
here it's a blatant ripoff and racism
yeah that's my
is racism and a blatant ripoff I don't
think it's a lot of these racists really
but Mark you were the one that made the
argument no I didn't you tried to make
that connection
yeah you did Mark I just said his name
and then I showed the lower the brand
and then you guys made myself in the
races what you have against an ego
oh um
he's a cool designer he could say it he
also doesn't speak English at all what
he's right here man what are you doing
bro
I'm talking about Alex he doesn't speak
English yeah
that's literally what I said literally
what yeah